hello and congratulations you've
obtained the lucrative job of scout for
the class nine six spacecraft Icarus at
first glance straight looks as if it's
resting on the laurels of old school
hyper-fast gory first-person shooters
like doom and quake but working within
these confines and throwing in the
roguelike structure strafe emerges as a
uniquely thrilling shooter with plenty
of charm in its own right it teeters
between being mindlessly fun and
cautiously strategic to the backdrop of
a perfectly executed electronic
soundtrack the game nails its core
gameplay loot blasts foes and scavenge
to survive the next fight the pace at
which you - jump and strafe makes you
nimble and each fight is a violent dance
that only ends once the last enemy is
down
though you choose a primary weapon to
start a run kiosks are scattered
throughout the game for free randomized
upgrades some more effective than others
additional weapons are scattered through
the world which are single-use and
varying effectiveness while a rocket
launcher or plasma rifle work well for
hardened foes a short-range needle gun
or sonic blaster aren't particularly
useful in most situations it's also
disappointing that for a game that
revolves around shooting most of the
guns lack impact the machine gun and
railgun feel downright piddly mutated
humans turrets spiders and acid tossing
foes populate the world and require you
to think fast and adapt to these threats
one misstep could spell disaster for
your run since damage comes Swift
forgetting to check your flanks or watch
your back or being too close to an
explosive projectile can be your undoing
like all rogue style games critical
mistakes deep into a run are incredibly
dejected but by the same token it's what
creates tension as you go further along
but it also induces a level of
repetition that isn't always inviting
shri features two currencies scrap for
armor and ammo and money for items at
shops you're never given too much of
either so part of survival is spending
these wisely while the onus is on you to
figure out the best use case scenario
for these items and upgrades many of
these elements aren't always abundantly
clear the more you experiment with
strafe the more Easter eggs and secrets
begin to reveal themselves jump to the
first level without choosing a gun and a
wrench will be your primary weapon play
the Wolfenstein 3d clone arcade machine
and upgrades have spit out one
particular highlight was finding the
superhot shotgun the game itself turns
into superhot where only time moves as
you move up until it runs out of ammo
Easter eggs like this instill the desire
to find more secrets and go beyond
simply finishing the final level
[Music]
though the start and tail end of each
level remains the same large portions
are procedurally generated drawing from
a handful of preset rooms rearranged in
sequence and orientation while this
keeps you guessing to an extent with
each run familiarity starts to creep in
if there's a fault here it's that stray
fails to introduce truly unexpected
challenges thankfully the game's
redeeming qualities are enough to keep
you hooked and one of the strongest
hooks is the soundtrack sometimes you
get the urge to hop into the game just
to listen to these songs as if you
ordered music with a side of gameplay
[Music]
level 3 - - is a dark and frightening
place with the music to match the
blaring SIF melody over a catchy rhythm
coalesce with up-tempo beat and
industrial percussions that make the
song grimy and horrifying and inspiring
all at the same time level 2 - one is
your first encounter with open air to
relieve the claustrophobia of the first
levels as you mow down new enemies a
sense of wonder excitement and
desperation is instilled by the
infectious electronic rock track that
you can't stop humming or get out of
your head
moments of chaos are bookended by the
tranquil and ethereal tracks in each
exit room and Shop the music never loses
its grip and it never disappoints and it
becomes part of straights personality
adding a significant layer of enjoyment
though the first levels of Icarus feel
pulled straight out of the original doom
with its tight corridors and dim
lighting you begin to see subsequent
levels open up and tie together the low
five retro aesthetic is colourful and
clean which makes for both silly and
terrifying enemies at splattered
excessive gore and literally paint the
town red any semblance of story is told
through the environment alone and it's
one of the aspects that make the game
alluring it makes for quirky and varied
set pieces for frantic shooting and it's
enough to lead you along to the
satisfying conclusion
however the game isn't without its
technical issues enemies occasionally
shoot at you through walls or glitch out
and zip across a room and either be gone
entirely or sneak up behind you to cause
unnecessary damage later levels had a
few inexplicable framedrops thankfully
these issues are rare enough as to not
entirely ruin an otherwise refined
experience as unforgiving repetitive and
frustrating as it can be the urge to
jump back into the game and take out
that frustration on the hordes of
enemies to the tune of the most proper
soundtrack with a toybox of guns is hard
to resist
straight where's its influence is on its
sleeve but stands out on its own as a
fun intense and fast-paced shooter with
distinguishable charisma wow we've never
seen results this impressive before
you're more than ready to travel to the
edge of the galaxy
[Music]
you